[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit heinz
wolf uns marietta slomka guten abend
es war ja ein wochenlanges zähes ringen
zwischen gesundheitsminister lauterbach
und justizminister buschmann bis sie
schließlich ihren gemeinsamen entwurf
für ein neues
infektionsschutzgesetz vorlegten gruner
maßnahmen reloaded sozusagen dass die
beiden sich überhaupt geeinigt haben war
schon schwer genug aber jetzt kommen
natürlich auch noch die bundesländer ins
spiel zumal die beiden bundesminister
ihnen sowieso die hauptlast der
gestaltung und entscheidung überlassen
um die begeisterung darüber hält sich
bei ihnen in grenzen heute traf man sich
zur video konferenz eines der
hauptthemen wann und wo soll ab herbst
maske getragen werden heike slansky
berichtet
manchmal hilft ein blick über den
tellerrand in der schweiz gelten keine
landesweiten coruna maßnahmen mehr in
österreich auch nicht in frankreich
wurde der korona pass aufgehoben und in
dänemark seit monaten keinerlei
beschränkungen mehr corona wird hier
behandelt wie jede andere
viruserkrankung in deutschland dagegen
wird gerungen und gestritten
gesundheitsministerkonferenz mit karl
lauterbach der an coruna erkrankt ist
trotz flotter impfung sein konzept für
den herbst masken im innenraum es sei
denn man ist getestet genesen oder
frisch geimpft die impfung allerdings
darf nicht älter als drei monate sein
kritik aus den ländern es kann kritik
aus den ländern gerade zu dem thema drei
monate impfstatus versus maske und auch
zu den parametern es gibt schon noch
fundierte aussagen dass man nach steuern
muss hatte nicht das gefühl dass es
möglich angekommen ist beim
bundesgesundheitsminister und das da wir
ernst genommen wurden impfen als anreiz
für einen masken freien zugang zu
restaurants oder veranstaltungen der
minister plädiert für die vierte impfung
am besten gleich für alle und macht
druck gegen die ständige impfkommission
die das ablehnt entsprechend wütend die
reaktion rüdiger von kries kontert es
wäre besser wenn lauterbach seine zunge
etwas besser im griff denn die stiko
empfiehlt vier mal impfen erst ab 70
auch der international renommierte
immunologe staunt nicht schlecht über
den minister er sieht eine vierte eben
vom kritisch meiner meinung nach ist die
schutz vor schwere erkrankung nach der
dritten impfung bereits langfristig mehr
als 95 prozent mehr kann das immunsystem
eigentlich gar nicht schaffen das ist
sehr gut exzellent tatsächlich während
auf der anderen seite die gegenwärtigen
impfstoffe eigentlich keinen guten
schutz bieten vor ansteckung und davor
dass man andere dann wieder ansteckt
dauer impfen selbstschutz oder
fremdschutz der minister hat bereits die
noch nicht zugelassenen angepassten
impfstoff bestellt doch an der
wirksamkeit zweifeln wissenschaftler die
frage ob die neuen impfstoffe
überhaupt eine immunreaktion auslösen
die nennenswert ist und insbesondere ob
sie vor ansteckung schützen und dafür
dass man andere ansteckt die ist
vollkommen offen das muss man erst
klinische untersuchung zeigen meine
vorhersage wer das weiß ich ja eher
skeptisch bin was gilt wann wie oft soll
man sich impfen lassen mit welchem
impfstoff fragen die auch die
fachpolitiker umtreiben es ist jetzt das
dritte japan emi und wir müssen
insbesondere das ist auch ein wunsch der
gesundheitsminister und
gesundheitsministerinnen dass wir
regelungen finden die die menschen noch
verstehen die wissen auch woran sich
dann halten können und die sie vor allem
auch nachvollziehen können auch
innerhalb der fdp regt sich widerstand
das neue schutzkonzept für den herbst
und winter muss noch durch den bundestag
ausgang offen
der bundesgesundheitsminister ist sonst
zugeschaltet noch aus seiner häuslichen
isolation corona krank wie wir wissen
guten abend herr lauterbach wie geht es
ihnen denn im namen versorgt mir geht es
wieder besser obwohl ich sagen muss also
dass ich waren die symptome stärker als
ich erwartet hatte also sehr starken
mussten hatte hohes fieber habe bugs so
mitgenommen ich war ja viel magie ist
also dass es schon keine kleinigkeit
gewesen aber jetzt nicht auf dem weg der
besserung
umso mehr wäre es natürlich schön wenn
es dann im herbst ein impfstoff wieder
gibt der einen auch immun macht also der
nicht nur vor ganz schweren verläufen
womöglich mit krankenhaus schutz sondern
der auch vor ansteckung schützt sind sie
da den optimistisch dass diese
bemühungen jetzt wo auch die europäische
zulassungsbehörde der offenbar in
bewegung kommt bis oktober fruchten ja
das glaube ich schon es sind ja mit den
unternehmen die hier am start in dem
engen austausch die daten die wir bisher
gesehen haben dem gestik weist darauf
hin dass werden wir auch zusammen mit
dem paul ehrlich instituts das also die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass die impfstoffe
die ende september kommen oder anfang
oktober kommen dass die auch vor
ansteckung schützen ob die perfekte
schützen glaube ich nicht aber dort
nicht besser als der listige impfstoff
somit haben wir jetzt sehr gute
impfstoffe die von schweren verlauf
schützt aber nicht ganz gut vor der
ansteckung dann wird es wieder so sein
dass man sich auch vor der ansteckung
einigermaßen sicher sagen kann was ich
jetzt nicht genau verstehen ist wenn man
dann sagen mal in drei monaten solche
impfstoffe hat wieso rufen sie denn dann
jetzt moment dazu auf dass ich alles
schon das system von kohlen sollen also
warum soll ich mich jetzt noch mal
impfen dem impfstoff der mich vor
ansteckung nicht schutz und dann drei
monaten sagt mit der arzt jetzt muss
aber erst noch mal ein bisschen warten
mit der nächsten impfung ja das tue ich
ja nicht das wird immer wieder falsch
ich hoffe die älteren menschen auf und
die menschen in pflegeeinrichtungen sind
wir haben doch gesagt verlasse die
fürther impfung damit gab es doch auch
als den streit mit der stimmung nein ich
habe nicht gesagt für alle die für die
impfung nur darauf hingewiesen dass wir
auch eine botschaft für die unter
60-jährigen oder die unter 70-jährigen
benötigt man zum beispiel soll eine
solche impfung dann stattfindenden
absprache mit dem arzt oder also wovon
hängt das ab zum beispiel jemand der
ganz besonders viele kontakte hat die
man zum beispiel der krank ist und somit
viele risiken trägt aber sie sind ja
noch alle verdampfung geholt und gesagt
das sinnvoll ist ganz genau das ist
richtig also bin ich auch sehr sehr
viele kontakte habe daher war es nur
eine frage der zeit bis wann ich mich
also man stellt sich kann man folgendes
sagen diejenigen die richtig hohe
risiken tragen diejenigen die älter sind
was die pflegebedürftig sind die jacken
haben wie die krankheit schwerer
verlaufen desto gerade erkrankungen wie
sollten aus meiner sicht auf die neuen
impfstoffe nicht warten weil bis dahin
kann man sich infiziert hat und dann
kann der verlauf ein sehr schwerer sein
somit also ist das abwarten für
diejenigen die jetzt im risiko stehen
einfach falsch und davon raten auch
übrigens fast alle also internationalen
wissenschaftler absolvieren sondern
nicht jetzt monatelang warten auf neue
impfstoffe wenn man die impfstoffe die
wir jetzt haben ganz zuverlässig vor tod
und schwerer krankheit schützen also für
die die jetzt jedoch keine hatten zum
beispiel
das war jetzt auch nicht unbedingt zur
allgemeinen klarheit bei trägt also die
stiko sagt dies dann hieß es lauterbach
empfiehlt für alle jetzt sagen sie in
der nähe eigentlich auch nicht unbedingt
für alle und genauso verwirrend sind
diese neuen masken regeln die sie jetzt
mit dem buschmann ausgehandelt haben das
also diejenigen die vor drei monaten
spätestens geimpft wurden sind zum
beispiel keine maske dann in innenräumen
tragen müssen im herbst der soll das
denn kontrollieren also dann steht man
im restaurant und sagt zeig mir deinen
impfausweis oder aber die allgemeinen
pässe dies war ja lange hatten die gibt
es dann ja nicht mehr also ich glaube es
wird im moment auch sehr viel wie
stiftet durch leute die verwirrung
stiften wollen zum beispiel ich habe nie
gesagt dass alle jüngeren leute sich
jetzt impfen lassen sondern das ist
einfach falsch das wird immer wieder
unterstellt was aber nicht richtig das
habe ich nie gesagt und so ist es auch
bei der frage wer hat dann eine ausnahme
wenn man also im herbst mit maske in die
innenräume muss zum beispiel also ins
restaurant die allgemeine regel ist ganz
simpel also die masken pflicht ist dann
grundsätzlich benötigt und das heißt ins
restaurant geht man dann in die länder
das umgesetzt haben mit der maske das
gleiche gilt auch für
kulturveranstaltungen
veranstaltung öffentliche
veranstaltungen jeder art als mitbürger
master uns war es wird aber eine
ausnahme angeboten für diejenigen die es
richtig sind ja das aber ja verstanden
was habe ich ja eben auch noch gesagt
aber wie sollen denn aussehen und vor
allem warum diese willkürliche zahl drei
monate also hiermit am restaurant
eingang und guckt sich den frischen
impfausweis an und
was man einen tag über diese drei monate
ist es ist doch irgendwie so ein
löchriger käse der da geschaffen wird
das ist nicht wichtig also mit
grenzwerten arbeiten geplant ist dass
auf der korona waren einfach das
zertifikat so lange wie die drei monate
noch nicht um sind eine andere farbe hat
somit also dass noten normale ebens
zertifikat was ja blau erscheint wurde
damals im grünen erscheinen zu dass beim
reingehen jeder sofort sie ja das ist
ein falsches zertifikat wir dürfen uns
auch nicht also die sache sehr schwer
machen wo es nicht nötig ist die länder
die restaurants die gaststätten wir
haben hier alle erfahrungen damit dass
früher war es noch viel komplizierter
zweig plus zu kontrollieren oder ag zu
kontrollieren hier wird einfach die coma
war dem richter entgegen guard und
fertig ist meinen sie dass das so durch
den bundestag gehen wird in anbetracht
auch der kritik die es aus den ländern
gibt dass sie nicht genau wissen wann
sie denn jetzt was einführen sollen
schneeketten wann liegt schnee in corona
sachen
das sind ja eindeutige und auch sehr
simple kriterien die wir geschrieben
haben hohe sterbezahlen schwere verläufe
die krankenhaus zu können kann also kann
nicht mehr so viele fälle aufnehmen
intensiv sachsen sind überlastet das
sind ja auch alles dinge die wir schon
mal gemacht haben das wird dann von den
landesregierungen wird es dann
festgelegt und dann gibt es auf der
grundlage hat entsprechende erlasse das
haben wir doch alles schon getan also
zuerst ist die kritiker wirklichkeit
eine andere die kritik ist die wir
wollen zum teil an regeln anknüpfen die
wir schon mal gehabt haben und viele
wollen das nicht so einfach sagen wir
wollen einfach hierzu wird weiterleben
die vorher cola ist zu ende der erbs
kann doch so einfach sagen wir also
lasst uns auf einer durchseuchung
ankommen das lehnen wir aber
regierungsseitig ab da wäre ich auch
einmal metern buschmann weil das würde
einfach zu viele todesfälle kosten und
das können wir nicht akzeptieren
herr lauterbach danken für das gespräch
und weiterhin gute besserung
ich danke ihnen
das interview aufgezeichnet euch jetzt
erstmal die nachrichten von hans wolf
ein anwesen des früheren us-präsidenten
trump ist nach dessen eigenen angaben
von fbi ermittlern durchsucht worden
während trump selbst in new york war
fand die razzia in lago in palm beach
florida statt nach medienberichten geht
es um regierungsdokumente die trump
dorthin mitgenommen haben soll trump
kritisierte die razzia als weder
notwendig noch angemessen
china hat seine militärmanöver vor der
küste taiwans den fünften tag in folge
fortgesetzt
dabei kamen die luftwaffe und die marine
zum einsatz wie die volksarmee mitteilte
taiwan warf china vor mit den übungen
einen angriff auf die insel
vorzubereiten und hielt seinerseits
militärübungen mit scharfer munition an
china hatte seine mannen über vergangene
woche begonnen nach einem teil waren
besuch der us spitzenpolitiker and nancy
pelosi
in kenia haben die bürgerinnen und
bürger einen neuen präsidenten sowie
parlaments abgeordnete gewählt nachdem
es in der vergangenheit oft unruhen
gegeben hatte sind die wahl diesmal
offenbar friedlich verlaufen der
bisherige vizepräsident und erfolgreiche
geschäftsmann ruto hat gute chancen dass
sein parteifreund der amtierende
präsident kenia unterstützt allerdings
den langjährigen oppositionsführer und
tinga bestimmende themen im wahlkampf
waren die schwächelnde wirtschaft und
die hohe inflation die
japanische stadt nagasaki hat der opfer
des atombombenabwurfs vor 77 jahren
gedacht der bürgermeister von nagasaki
warnte angesichts des russischen kriegs
gegen die ukraine vor der bedrohung
durch atomwaffen sie sei eine greifbare
und gegenwärtige krise am 9 august 1945
hatten die usa drei tage nach hiroshima
eine atombombe auf nagasaki abgeworfen
dadurch starben etwa 70.000 menschen
kleine krieg ließ heute die nachricht
aufhorchen dass es auf der krim schwere
explosionen gegeben hat
auf einem russischen militär flughafen
in der nähe eines badeortes sind
offenbar ein oder mehrere munitionslager
in die luft geflogen viele beobachter
vermuten dahinter eine ukrainische
aktion das wäre dann der erste angriff
auf die krim seit russland sie sich vor
zwölf jahren einverleibt hat die
russische seite wiegelt jedoch ab es
habe keine feindeinwirkung gegeben das
ukrainische
verteidigungsministerium erklärte
zunächst nur dass man die ursache der
detonation nicht benennen könne und
fügte dann nicht ohne süffisanz hinzu
wie wichtig es sei an solchen orten
strikte brandschutz regeln wie das
rauchverbot einzuhalten damit nahmen die
ukraine quasi vorweg was die russische
seite kurz darauf als erklärung lieferte
das eine missachtung von
sicherheitsregeln die explosionen
ausgelöst habe die nächstgelegene front
ist jedenfalls rund 200 kilometer
entfernt in der provinz rasse dorthin
hat unsere reporterin anne brühl
ukrainische soldaten begleitet
helm und weste tragen wir zu unserer
sicherheit so hatten es die soldaten
verlangt die uns mitnehmen zu ihren
stellungen nahe der südlichen front über
leere straßen vorbei an verlassenen
dörfern
andré führt uns zum unterstand wie fast
alle soldaten nennt auch er uns nur
seinen kampfnamen
wir brauchen so viele waffen wie möglich
in aller kürzester zeit damit wir diesen
krieg schnell beenden können ich möchte
betonen dass heute die ukraine nicht nur
ihr eigenes territorium frauen und
kinder verteidigt sondern auch europa
als ganzes
wo genau wir sind dürfen wir nicht sagen
die gräben hier stammen noch vom
russischen vormarsch erzählt uns der
kommandeur der truppe
jetzt sind wir auf ihrer position einige
schützengräben waren noch intakt aber
ein paar haben wir auch selbst begraben
vielmehr darf er uns nicht erzählen zum
beispiel wie genau die angeblichen
fortschritte für die ukraine im süden
denn aussehen satans leute haben
kampfpause viele hier haben sich
freiwillig gemeldet
in einem der dörfer treffen wir menschen
als der krieg kam sind sie einfach
geblieben
sie schießen die ganze zeit tag und
nacht mit allem was sie haben das ist
normal
der strom funktioniert noch meistens
jedenfalls der zeitlupe über die
soldaten bekommt sie lebensmittelpakete
was aber fragen wie ihr macht sie wenn
die kämpfe zu heftig werden
wenn es nur ein leichter angriff ist
bleiben wir in unseren stühlen hier
sitzen bei einem schweren angriff gehen
wir runter in den keller und verstecken
uns dort
da geht es runter in den keller
lukas hat das hier schon sehr oft
gemacht sie und ihr beinamputierter man
jede nacht schlafen die beiden im keller
wir fühlen das ist der sicherste platz
wir wissen das natürlich nicht so genau
hier schlafen wir
jede begegnung hat die ukrainische armee
für uns organisiert nächster stopp
zerstörtes russisches kriegsgerät
triumphal klingt andré dort nicht
wir müssen diesen krieg so schnell wie
möglich beenden mit so wenig opfern wie
möglich von unserer und der russischen
seite lasst sie in irland gehen und
machen was immer sie wollen wir haben
sie nicht angegriffen sie sind in unser
land gekommen
die ukraine sprechen von gegenoffensive
die russen verstärken ihre truppen an
der südlichen front kämpfen sie weiter
unerbittlich
einer korrektur ich habe eben gesagt
dass die hosen die krim sich vor zwölf
jahren einverleibt haben das ist falsch
das man 2014 und 15 nicht nur für die
ukraine und für europas demokratien wäre
es jedenfalls eine katastrophe wurde
putin diesen krieg gewinnen was immer
man dann unter sieg verstehen könnte
auch für die nachbarn in belarus wäre
das katastrophal der belarussischen
opposition jedenfalls würde ein
untergang der ukraine die letzte
hoffnung nehmen heute ist es zwei jahre
her dass sich in belarus hunderttausende
erhoben und sie vergessen nicht axel
sturm berichtet
es sind augenblicke des glücks an die
sich igor eliasch erinnert an
zärtlichkeit an verbundenheit an seine
frau
ich bin sehr beeindruckt wie katja
dieser prüfung standhält wie sie sich in
dieser situation verhält die
journalistin katharina andré war rechts
war 26 jahre alt als sie mit ihrer
kollegin daria schulz over die proteste
vor zwei jahren in minsk ins internet
streamt das waren proteste gegen eine
gefälschte wahl gegen einen
gewaltherrscher gegen brutalität
festnahmen und folter für eine hellere
zukunft eines ganzen landes
die beiden frauen wurden zu haftstrafen
verurteilt schulz over zu 2 andré war zu
acht jahren und drei monaten
es kann keinen zweifel daran geben dass
es sich um rache für ihre arbeit handelt
dass dieses ganze strafverfahren direkt
mit ihrer arbeit in zusammenhang steht
vieles an beweismaterial war so
konstruiert dass sie angeblich
staatsgeheimnisse einer ausländischen
organisation zugänglich gemacht haben
soll
andrä war und schulz over hatten für
einen polnischen sender gearbeitet
belarus heute auch wenn die sonne
scheint ein reich des schreckens
hunderte journalistinnen und
oppositionelle in haft willkür verfahren
die proteste im land verstummt viele
sagen nur aus einem einzigen grund weil
russlands staatschef lukaschenko
politisches überleben sichert aber eine
bootsfahrt mit wladimir putin ist
gefährlich die see kann rau sein und
geschenke gibt es nicht
lukaschenko hat zum gegenwärtigen
zeitpunkt gewonnen die frage ist aber zu
welchem preis dieser preis ist sehr hoch
und bezahlen muss ihnen belarus
mit russlands sogenannter militärischer
spezialoperationen der ukraine
präsentiert putin seinem freund lukas
schenkel eine dicke rechnung für seine
dienste lukaschenko bleibt präsident
putins truppen aber stehen in belarus
russland verteilt großzügig kredite aber
vielleicht verlangt moskau irgendwann
auch nach wähler russischen soldaten an
der front
das land bezahlt mit einem verlust an
souveränität mit einer wirtschaftskrise
in die es wegen der sanktionen gerutscht
ist es bezahlt mit einer tiefen spaltung
der gesellschaft
gespalten ist auch die weitgehend im
exil arbeitende opposition inzwischen
sogar die galionsfigur svetlana turn of
skye umstritten in den eigenen reihen
einige sind enttäuscht vom bisher
erreichten
vor zwei jahren fühlte sich belarus nach
aufbruch an nach freiheit vielleicht
heute scheint all das schon sehr lange
her zu sein
und nach deutschland heinz macht weiter
mit dem blick auf die wirtschaft
wichtige wasserstrassen wieder einführen
aktuell teils nur niedrigwasser und das
hat auch wirtschaftliche auswirkungen
nicht nur für die lade mengen und kosten
der transporte an sich sondern stefanie
bareth möglicherweise auch wenn man auf
das wirtschaftswachstum insgesamt schaut
ja weil die pegelstände seit beginn der
woche nochmals gesunken sind gerät
einfach der güterverkehr auf
deutschlands flüssen zunehmend ins
stocken das bringt auch den
wirtschaftsmotor weiter ins stottern
ökonomen rechnen jetzt im dritten
quartal mit einer deutlichen abkühlung
der konjunktur denn die
binnenschifffahrt ist ein immens
wichtiger logistik baustein für die
deutsche industrie große mengen an
heizöl und diesel werden über den rhein
nach deutschland importiert getreide
rohstoffe chemikalien und kohle kommen
über die flüsse immer die pegelstände im
blick besonders dramatisch aktuell der
rhein pegel an der engstelle bei koblenz
hier haben schiffe im moment nur noch
einen halben meter wasser unterm kiel
nötig sind aber anderthalb um voll
beladen fahren zu können
deshalb wird derzeit nur ein drittel der
chefs kapazität geladen kunden benötigen
nun auf drei schiffe um ihre lauf
lieferaufträge zu erfüllen was auf die
preise durchschlägt größtes problem die
erzeugt die kohlekraftwerke weil gas aus
russland knapp ist sind sie für die
stromerzeugung besonders wichtig nun
verzögert das niedrigwasser den kohle
nachschub und einzelne energieversorger
wollen deshalb bereits die leistung
drosseln zuletzt erlebte die
binnenschiffer 2018 derart niedrige
wasserstände auch hier waren die
folgekosten hoch das phänomen also nicht
neu anpassungsmaßnahmen wie die
vertiefung von fahren etwa mahnt die
binnenschiffer dann aber bis dieses
problem gelöst ist dürfte wohl noch viel
wasser den rhein herunter fließen
vielen dank
der diesjährige georg büchner preis geht
an die in der türkei geborene autorin
emine sevgi özdamar die jury sagt die
deutsche literatur verdanke ihr einen
hoch poetischen sound ihrem
autobiografisch geprägten roman
theaterstücke und erzählungen
thematisieren oft die deutsch türkische
geschichte die auszeichnung soll im
november verliehen werden
gut eine woche nach dem finale bei der
frauenfußball-wm war bundeskanzler
scholz heute beim deutschen fußball bund
dabei ging es auch um die
unterschiedlichen prämien für die frauen
und männerteams
der kanzler trifft die dfb spitze und
drängt auf eine gleichbehandlung von
frauen und männerteams scholz forderte
schon während der em gleiche bezahlung
mit dem schlagwort equal pay hatte er
fahrt in die debatte gebracht und er ist
zudem für eine angleichung der prämien
ich finde das ist etwas politisches
anders als die gehaltsverhandlung die
erfolgreiche spieler und spielerinnen
anderswo führen und deshalb macht es
schon sinn dass man dort über gleiche
prämien diskutiert auch bundestrainerin
voss-tecklenburg plädierte im aktuellen
sportstudio für eine anpassung der titel
prämien bei frauen und männern
mannschaft für den titel das gleiche
auszuschütten aber dann bitte bei den
männern ein bisschen weniger bei uns ein
bisschen mehr weil ich finde es immer
noch überdimensioniert deshalb bin ich
zumindest bereit in unseren gremien auch
darüber zu diskutieren ob unser über
jahrzehnte muss man ja sagen gewachsenes
prämiensystem noch zeitgemäß ist seit
der em sind die forderungen
grundgehälter chancengleichheit
anstoßzeiten zur primetime mehr
sichtbarkeit und akzeptanz das treffen
heute hat gezeigt der wille zu
veränderungen ist vorhanden
wenn in münchen morgen die
eröffnungsfeier beginnt soll es sich ein
bisschen so anfühlen wie
1972 bei den olympischen spielen den
olympischen spielen die sich als welt
gedächtnis gegraben haben die so schön
begann ist das grauen kam ermordete
israelische athleten ausgerechnet in
deutschland auch daran wird in den
nächsten tagen erinnert aber die
european championships sollen vor allem
an den heiteren geist von 72 anknüpfen 9
europameisterschaften ausgetragen in
historischen wettkampfstätten aus
münchen stefan leifert
es ist schon eine gehörige portion
nostalgie dabei wie münchen sein
weltberühmtes zeltdach grad neu in szene
setzt back to the roots zurück zu den
dächern haben die veranstalter das
getauft was hier am morgen über die
bühnen geht eine mischung aus sport und
kultur wettkampf festival und party in
einem 50 jahre nach olympia beschwört
eine stadt den geist von 72
heißt eigentlich dass wir zurück wollen
zum vermächtnis von 72 und zwar nur zu
dem positiven vermächtnis bis die
schatten des attentats die spiele
verdunkelten war münchen zu olympia eine
blaupause für sportveranstaltungen der
moderne leicht und transparent nahbar
und fröhlich die gigantomanie heutiger
sportevents war noch weit weg
toni engelhardt war ganz nah dran an
olympia 72 hier in der talsporthalle
koordinierte er als mittzwanziger die
turnt wettkämpfe dass dieselbe halle
derselbe boden 50 jahre später wieder
wettkampfstätte wird findet er klasse
weil diese tolle anlage mit leben
gefüllt wird und was gibt es besser wenn
ich war in den verschiedenen
europäischen städten in turin und weiter
die sportanlagen verkommen gänzlich und
hier in münchen wird das aufrecht
gehalten und wertgeschätzt
nachhaltigkeit ist das schlagwort von
münchens mini olympia 2022 neun
sportarten 9 europameisterschaften und
kein neubau das olympiastadion für die
leichtathletik die einstige
regattastrecke in oberschleißheim für
die kanu und rudern em im olympiapark
mountainbike und bmx
zieleinlauf für den marathon ist
münchens innenstadt und der
geschichtsträchtige königsplatz ist
gerade ein beachvolleyball stadion der
eintritt ist frei die european
championships wollen groß und nama
zugleich sein und diese championship mit
13 locations und du siehst überall was
und du kannst überall hinkommt wenn ganz
viele sachen kostenlos rein derzeit
schon besonderes erlebnis also ich finde
das ist schon mal andere hausnummer
dieses sportevent will mehr sein als
sport fast ein dutzend bühnen stehen im
olympiapark bereit für musik djs
künstler dorian und felicitas sind für
ihre installationen dafür extra aus
berlin gekommen
teil dieser ganze sportveranstaltung zu
sein gleichzeitig als künstler auf
unserem zusammenzuarbeiten und unsere
werke einer großen plattform zu bieten
und sich zu präsentieren
sehr demonstrativ versucht münchen ein
großereignis der liebenswerten art zu
kreieren tastet sich deutschland hier
etwa vorsichtig an eine neue olympia
bewerbung heran wenn wir mit unserer
multi sport veranstaltung hier zeigen
können dass sportgroßveranstaltungen
wieder möglich sind dass sie nachhaltig
sein können dass sie die menschen
mitnehmen wenn wir diese atmosphäre
schaffen kann ich mir auch vorstellen
dass sich deutschland noch mal für
olympische spiele bewerben wird
4700 sportler kämpfen dann ab übermorgen
um 177 goldmedaillen der sieg in der
disziplin olympia nostalgie ist münchen
schon heute nicht mehr zu nehmen
das war's dann uns weiter geht's gleich
mit der reportage reihe 37° heute mit
dem verheißungsvollen titel biturbo
besucher und bewohner und um 29 gibt es
dann unsere heute schneit update mit da
sein könnte mir
[Musik]
schon genannte und herzlich willkommen
zum wetter der extremen dürre situation
in europa ändert sich nur wenig und
jetzt haben wir auch noch eine
hochdruckbrücke die vom atlantik bis in
den osten europas reicht sonst erreicht
uns hier auch noch relativ warm als
heiße luft und so steigen die
temperaturen im westen deutschlands auf
30 grad und knapp darüber ja und regen
ist weiterhin nicht in sicht bis sonntag
in deutschland kaum nach osten und
südosten in einzelne gewitter möglich
richtung spanien ein bis zehn liter viel
zu wenig regen als ich richtung italien
da kann es mit kräftigen schauern und
gewittern durchaus bis zu 70 liter auf
den quadratmeter
geben ja in der nacht ist es trocken und
überwiegend sternenklar richtung ostsee
klar dass auf teilweise bildet sich
nebel und die temperaturen sinken auf 9
grad an den alpen und 10 grad zum
beispiel in der norddeutschen tiefebene
deutlich milder richtung rhein main
gebiet bei 18 grad morgen gibt es viel
sonnenschein und wenige wolken dafür
kräftigem ostwind und er kann durch sein
ist dann erträglicher vor allem bei den
höheren temperaturen bis zu 32 grad im
südwesten deutschlands unter am
niederrhein auch erträglicher an den
küsten mit werten um die 22 grad die
nächsten tage steigen die temperaturen
weiter am donnerstag komplett trocken
bis 33 am freitag dann im süden einzelne
gewitter am samstag im osten und dann
bis 35 grad ein schöner